la cour suprême des etats-unis a reconnu
le droit à l'avortement dans l'art héros
vivrait dans 1973 en avril dernier au
son des manifestations d pour ou contre
l'avortement
la cour a entendu la cause de la
louisiane qui plutôt que de contester le
droit à l'avortement a adopté une loi en
2014 pour obliger les médecins qui
pratiquent l'avortement à obtenir une
autorisation d'exercer dans un hôpital
situé à moins de 50 kilomètres du lieu
de l'intervention officiellement
l'intention était de protéger la santé
de la femme en cas de complications qui
était en jeu aujourd'hui c'était
vraiment des lois qui visent les
cliniques donc forcer les cliniques à
fermer leurs portes afin de limiter au
plus possible
l'accessibilité sans toutefois le rendre
illégal ce qui contreviendrait à la
décision de rovigo est donc en fait ce
sont des lois des tournées et des lois
qu'on appelle des choix donc en fait qui
lorsqu elles s'accumulent
ce type de loi là donc viennent
effectivement rendre inaccessible à
pratiquer sans la rendre illégal dans
les faits la loire et entraîné la
fermeture de deux cliniques sur les
trois qui pratiquent l'avortement
louisiane les quatre juges dits libéraux
ont trouvé la loi trop restrictive et
trop similaire à celle du texas que la
cour avait rejeté en 2016
la surprise est venue du juge en chef
conservateur john roberts qui était
d'accord avec la loi mais qui a voté
contre
au nom du respect du précédent de la
chose jugée
un autre revers en cour suprême pour
l'administration trump qui s'est dit
déçu et pour les quelques manifestants
venus à la cour suprême dans la tente du
jugement i'm very end
c'est une lourde perte pour les femmes
de louisiane et leur droit à la santé 17
femmes women
en fait les groupes anti-avortement
n'ont certainement pas dit leur dernier
mot
rien n'empêche les états ne partait de
restreindre l'accès par d'autres voies
que ce soit la limite de nombre de
semaines le consentement parental
le temps d'attenté entre un premier
rendez vous et un second rendez vous
donc les stratégies sont multiples et on
l'a vu dans les derniers mois également
avec la question de la pandémie et
certains états qui ont tenté d'utiliser
la crise sanitaire au restreint le droit
à l'avortement également à la cour
suprême entre libéraux et conservateurs
quatre contre cinq dont deux nommés par
le président trempe
la ligne est très mince la nomination
des juges est un enjeu majeur de
l'élection du 3 novembre
jean michel leprince traits du canada
montréal